hello there sorry about the delayed um
yeah there's some technical difficulties
and and sorry you have to look at me at
the weird angle but I think it's it's a
fun angle to look at me um but anyway
um so hello I'm Chuck and I'm going to
give this talk about hypothesis so
um like all my presentation I always
said that the first lie is the most
important slide because you got the link
to get this slide right so uh you don't
have to ask like oh where can I get a
slice or things like that but you've got
the link here already so which is great
and um also there are my contact details
I'm still on Twitter but uh I you know
if you prefer Mastodon same handle
you'll find me as well
um let's move on from there
um so
I I started the talk by asking a
question so you can't you you can answer
it yourself silently I I don't have to
know it but if you want to share feel
free to share in the chat
um so what's the most typical most
difficult part of writing the test
um
for me this is my answer for myself so
for me it's like importing the code
because sometimes you know
um when the you know when you have a big
uh kind of uh project that you have a
lot of multiple files and sometimes like
you don't import the code correctly and
then Partners can't find your code which
then it doesn't work
um another thing is to organize the test
so uh again if you have a huge project
right like you have a lot of a lot of
tests that you have to test it out and
um so yeah like uh if you know it can
get messy very quickly that you have a
lot of tests you don't know where they
put them and then they just like sketch
it everywhere and you just you know
after a while you just forget where they
are and just a big mess
the last thing is to think of some test
case because a lot of times when we do
tests we have to think of
um what example we should use to test uh
and how many examples we should get for
each test to kind of uh like kind of
deal with all the situation because when
it your code go into production anything
can happen so sometimes I ask myself is
my test good enough have I encountered
all the situation
so
um so so these are quite like
challenging things when we think about
testing and think about writing the test
for me I think that hypothesis can help
me Well it can't help me for importing
my messy code anyway
um but it will help me with organizing
the tests because
um instead of model tests that you have
to write you only need to write one test
and
um and the next thing is that uh it will
kind of help you to choose the edge
cases to test your code properly so
um before I jump into it and tell you
how uh I get help from hypothesis or how
hypothesis can help you uh that I'm
check I am working for Anaconda I was
involved in a lot of open source project
in the past I love open source so that's
why I love open source project I love
talking about them and I organize a lot
of events and conferences in the past
and I and I just love to go to all of
them so if you see me in the future uh
in any any events please come and say hi
to me I'm I won't you know I won't bite
you I I'm like you just say I'm I will
talk to you and like if you have any
questions or any um you know idea about
you know how to use this or that you
just talk to me I love talking to people
um so
let's go back to hypothesis
hypothesis before you know like what
hypothesis is I think you should know
what is a probability based testing
um so property based testing is uh I
would try to explain it by drawing some
example here so one is the like the uh
testing my property so that's the
property based testing another is
testing by example which is
what we call like when we do our normal
way of testing well I don't know you
know like normal is a very tricky word
right but anyways like how you usually
you know when we learn coding that's how
we do testing so that's that's the test
by example there
so first of all uh test by property is
that um I would think that the given is
obvious so later when you see the
example
maybe test by the property so as what
the name suggests we give the property
uh about the test so what what do I mean
by that so for example I have a function
that I do some calculation right so I
have an input X
is a bad name anyway X
um so what is X
so in if you test by example you have to
think of okay so X is a number right so
I'm doing some calculation here but do I
allow a floating Point number or do I
just allow integer uh do I allow any you
know let's say it's an integer do I
allow the negative integer do I allow
zero and all this state so I have to
think about all these examples that fit
the fit the uh the the the bill
um
but uh if we test my property uh is is a
we just given like what that X should be
right so for example X is a positive
number we can just say x is a positive
number that's what we provide for the
test so instead of putting all the
examples like okay it's a positive
number so I test one two three but not
testing zero because it should never be
zero and things like that
um I just say that it's a positive
number so
um the next thing is that uh because of
how it works just by the example I gave
you you know that test testing by
property uh half of the work is done if
you are already doing the typing right
so nowadays you know people write python
code and since uh what when they start
so Taipei was introduced like by stage
and then I think now it got fully
introduced maybe in three nine I'm not
sure if I'm wrong please forgive me but
uh you know it was introduced like you
know in in the modern kind of uh time
that when people write python code now
we type our variables so instead of like
you know python is famous for that
typing now people are more straight
about okay maybe we should be less messy
and and think ahead of what the the type
of our variables are and label them so
if you already done that if you follow
that kind of philosophy then half of the
work is done because testing by property
that's all the tests need to know what
that variable should be
for testing my example then you have to
take extra extra step right you look at
okay what's the typing so it's a it's an
integer that you got to find the example
that you should test there
um also you have to come up with good
example for example like maybe testing
one two and three is a bit silly because
if one pass and two parts then three
probably will pass right so you may not
want to test that uh instead maybe you
want to test something very big to see
if it blows up or things like that
um
so so yeah that that's what I just said
here Ash case if we have a good strategy
from hypothesis then uh the ash case
will be automatically found because we
cover the ground so by having a good
strategy or the tricky basis already
um given by the uh by hypothesis or the
the strategy that you're using but
testing my example every time you have
to think about Edge case and um so it's
not as systematic the hypothesis
so
um let's talk about hypothesis then like
now we know how uh we have test by
property so we know that
um you know the idea is that we only
need to provide the the type of the
variable instead of providing example of
the variable to be used in testing so
how does hypothesis do it
so there's two part uh mainly I just
break it down into a very very simple
kind of construct the first part is a
decorator so we need a
a decorator to kind of provide entry
point to the test so you know when we
write the test right we just have a test
function and then it got executed by pi
test or you're testing Suite uh you can
use unit tests if you want but I use Pi
test as an example here because Pi test
is my go-to
um so you need to have a decorator to
modify the test so the test become a
test that is work with hypothesis and
the next thing you have to provide is
the strategy again
like how do I know if this variable for
example is a positive integer what cases
to test so we have to write down the
strategy if whenever I see a positive
integer that's what I'm going to test
I'm going to test a few of the small
numbers and a few of the big numbers if
it's like for example a a non-negative
integer then we will increase zero so we
definitely need to test zero because
it's a special case
um so that's the strategy right what to
test and what not to test because they
are not needed
let's have a look at how hypothesis work
in action so uh this is a an example
that is actually in the documentation of
hypothesis
so this is very very simple right
there's like two function doing two
things uh you don't have to look at the
detail here uh but what it does is that
for one it it do the encoding of some
string and the other one is the reverse
is do the decoding of some string right
so
uh you don't have to look at it like I
said it's just an example of how like
you know there's two function written
that's doing coding and decoding so
uh how do we write a test for testing
this
so this is how you write the test for
testing this uh this is a hyper
simplified version of course you may
want to test more than just this but
this is an example so
um
first of all we need to decorator so The
Decorator is called given so in
hypothesis there are multiple decorator
you can use but most of the time you'll
be using giffen given is The Decorator
that you can actually
um provide a strategy for
for your variable for example this one
because remember we encode and decode
code some string right so we will use
the text strategy here from the
hypothesis strategies
and here you can see that when we apply
that that's like uh you know The
Decorator and a given and we said that
we use the text strategy because we have
the variable s here down there the
variable s will be a text and then it
will do this I call it round trip uh you
will see you see this again and again in
this talk so uh what it does is that
because this pair of function is doing
you know one is doing encoding the other
is decoding so if you encode something
and decode something it should go back
to what it was right so this is
basically testing that so s should be a
text okay so this is this is very very
simple
let's see if we can see how it works
also oop I can't see what is going on
here okay terminal that's what I want to
oh
okay let's do it this way okay let's
let's have a terminal can you see the
terminal actually you can't see the
terminal oops
I don't know why it happened like that
uh one second
so let me try again I think I thought I
was sharing the whole screen but I think
I made a mistake just once again I'll
fix it very very quickly
okay now we should go back to here yes
on
Yep this yeah there's a pop-up window in
my way anyway okay so now you see my I
you still can't see my window that's
very very annoying
why it's like this okay
so unfortunately the demo does not work
it doesn't show the whole screen that
I'm seeing so I can't show you the demo
but uh ideally I would like to see uh
show you how it works but it doesn't but
anyway you can try it at home if you
have downloaded the slides and you can
just like copy this text and try it at
home then if you run it it will be oops
yeah it will be my computer is doing
funny things now so you will see that
actually um you'll find an edge case if
you run this code right like you if you
if you get the code from this previous
slice and then you get the code from
this slice and then you run it and then
you find the edge case actually so this
is how like hypothesis work instead of
thinking about what to test and then you
will find that edge Case by just
providing the right strategy
so
um
I bought this for a scientific work so
uh why I'm kind of uh talking about
hypothesis here in the pi data
conference because uh
hypothesis work with numpy and actually
they are actually so a lot of people
think that okay it's a testing library
but then this actually works uh it
designed for for some of the scientific
calculation especially when you use a
lot of numeric calculation and use numpy
naturally and uh you can install that um
scientific stack that that we call uh
with this if you have seen this before
this means that if you just install
hypothesis then it's a lightweight
version of hypothesis just
consists of the core of what it is but
if you want some extra things for
example you want the extras uh
scientific stack then you have to put
the extra bit with the square bracket
here of numpy this is how you install
the extra bits that works with
hypothesis
and then you can import those uh tools
that works with numpy here by hypothesis
dot extra Dot numpy
and then yeah so it will provide
strategy to test for the scalar and the
D type so again strategies the number
one important thing in hypothesis
without the a robust strategy it won't
be very very helpful so um since now you
know hypothesis provide strategy for
numpy so you may as well get advantage
of it
um they also Panda support as well if
you install that extra bit for numpy
actually include the support for pandas
as well so it's the same we install it
and then all the extras are located here
so
um so for for the panda objects right so
pandas like the framing thing that you
would use would be data frame of course
sometimes series and index so they're
like you can have strategy for those so
um yeah so it's quite cool
again like all the details can find on
the documentation so please check out
the website there and some people don't
know that's why I mentioned it here so
um what if I'm very very lazy so again
is another thing that some people may
already use hypothesis but they never
try this out and don't you know is to um
not writing a test and let hypothesis
write it for you so how does it work uh
so you see the little like the the kind
of like a small you know small print
here you know all the details are you
know in the small print
um I hope you're still using typing
because for these to work uh typing
really does help if you're not using
typing then it can help but very limited
help can be given so
um we have a Ghostwriter so you know uh
kind of is for me it's very interesting
to name it this way because like imagine
that there's like you know
um it's kind of like surreal that
there's like someone like you know
there's a ghost holding a pen and write
all the test for users kind of like that
so it's written for you automatically so
what it does is it will use typing as a
hint so that's why I said I hope you're
still doing typing for your code because
that is how the Ghostwriter get the
information about what those variables
should be and then that's got uh applied
to writing your tests for you
and um so you will pick the strategy
depending on the type of your variable
and then is a CRI 2 actually so uh again
like I wish I could show you the
terminal and and like show you that but
unfortunately for I don't know why in
the Stream yet doesn't like me sharing
the whole screen for some reason I
haven't tried again so unfortunately you
you have to try it at home but the
command is super simple
um I will show you later
and also the code will be black so if
for example you don't want people to
know that you have been cheating right
you have been like the code is not
written by you what you can do is to use
black to help you to keep a consistent
format of your code so if you have been
a fan of black you have been using black
so your code will be more or less
following this kind of black format
right so it's a Auto formatter for those
of you who don't know what black the
live the package is
um so for for the ghost writer from
hypothesis it will also clean up the
code with black for you so uh it will be
consistent you know with your style of
writing which is already formatted by
black so nobody knows that you cheat
that's amazing
um
so uh yeah so this is how you can um
type in the command line again I can't
show you users try it at home if you if
you wish and of course you have to
install hypothesis but then you just
type in your terminal uh hypothesis uh
right and then the the this is the
package name so here we use an example G
zip gcip is came with the standard
Library so if you have a c python or any
kind of common uh you know python
installation that consists of gcip that
you would see the whole package the
whole module uh has been you know
scanned and then the test has been
written for it so it's really really
cool I wish I could show you but track
yourself trust me it's fun
um
so they're actually multiple ghost
writers so if you try that out yourself
you see that actually Ghost Writer is
quite smart it uses various strategy to
help write the test
um so there's like uh this these are the
the kind of the way that The Ghost
Writer write the test first is first
first is just to try to run the that
function right to make sure that it
Works
um so yeah the first thing about unit
testing is that thing works right so
we're using fast uh but if you're
expecting some kind of Errors then you
can also include that here because
sometimes you know your code May flow
some exception and stuff you can also
include that there so um
uh it knows that is expecting some error
um so yeah this is this is uh first one
of the thing that The Ghost Writer will
do
the other thing uh in that from
Independence is too hard to pronounce
this word uh but anyway what it what it
means is that uh for some functions
right uh if you apply it once if it's
work properly it's done so the job is
done if you apply it again it won't
change a thing sorting is a very good
example if you sort the list if it got
searched properly if it's not random
right it got it it's already in the
order that you wish so if you do the
same operation again then it won't
change a thing so this is what the
Ghostwriter is doing
um so it's very useful for that type of
function if you have written any of
those that you know applying it one
should already get the job done and it
should not be changed after
um I think this is the fun thing this is
the thing I said this happens all the
time is the round trip like the previous
example the encoding and decoding one so
when you apply so they come in a pair so
if you apply the first one and then
apply the second one you should go back
to where it started so uh we have a lot
of those actually in Python not just
python but in programming in general uh
because you know there are lots of
things that come in a pair Ah that's
beautiful for example we have the Json
Library again it's in the standard
Library if you have this C python
installed or any common distribution of
python installed then you should already
have it uh there are a lot of pairs for
example Json Doms and Json lows of
course they have Jason Dum and Json
loads as well without the S
um are they coming to pair uh if you
apply the first one it doesn't matter
which order actually like uh but and I
think it depends so okay yeah again of
course like if you apply Jason loads
first then you have to have a Json
string but if you apply Json tops then
it would be a dictionary so but anyway
uh you apply the two
um you know consecutively you should go
back to where it was so this is the
round trip and this is one of the things
that The Ghostwriter would do the ghost
writer is super smart for example if you
apply it to our previous example because
the we have hinted it by the name one is
called encode the other is called decode
so a hypothesis we know that they are
actually a pair
um so what if you have multiple ones
right if you put them in different
classes actually uh hypothesis will also
try to match the pair within the same
class so it's actually quite smart um
believe me I work on this a little bit
contribute a little bit to this part of
hypothesis and I'm so proud of it so
please check it out
and uh equivalent uh is is also quite
useful sometimes uh if you have a a
function that you know that it works
more or less the same as another
function that you trust is correct then
you can use this
um so this sometimes you know this is I
think this is like less uh frequency
that you come into it for example you
know I write my own power you know extra
path y kind of um function and then I
want to check it against them the one in
the math module because the one in the
math module probably is corrected right
so
um so yeah like things like that that
you can check it it's like checking
another function against one that you
believe is correct so it's kind of like
that
there's others there's like again less
use for example binary operation if you
have written some custom binary
operations uh operators then you can use
this to check and also we have things
again for numpy so we have you Funk
because we you know you when you have
the numpy you found when you know if you
applies to Ghostwriter and see some kind
of numpy stuff that it can you know that
can be applied and uh
uh goes right here we do that for you so
that's very cool so uh
yes I I wish I could show you again I
can't do this so uh it's coming to an
end don't worry
yeah you can try it at home so like I
said you have this the the the link of
the slides right so you can try it
yourself
um but before I end this talk I want to
kind of give give you a feel kind of you
know uh a warning or you know a grain of
salt because
um I am not like promoting you like to
say oh you must use hypothesis or things
like that because like any other things
like it really depends on like what
you're doing and what you want to
achieve so
um a few things to consider when you are
trying hypothesis or try to apply
hypothesis to your project is that um
tests can Arrangement can run much
slower if you have a big library for
example uh why uh people will ask like
oh why uh psychic learning is not using
hypothesis to test everything yet
because you know we have all the tools
that support numerical calculation and
you know they should use it I've talked
to the maintainer and they said that oh
actually it could be quite slow
sometimes because they have you know
succulent is a massive Library it
provides a lot of tools for people to
use so
um having hypothesis to generate all the
strategy for it can expand the the
testing
into a two of a massive kind of uh
testing that's why it would it will be
much slower and it may not be something
that is desirable for the team
and um tests can be harder to understand
is instead of having straightforward
examples sometimes
if you want to know what has been test
or what hasn't been tested you have to
really like Trace back and see what
hypothesis is doing so it's not as
straightforward as just writing some
examples
um another thing
especially when you're using a
Ghostwriter if you haven't typed your
code if hypothesis doesn't know what
type of those variables are it actually
doesn't save you a lot of time because
at the end you have to go back to the
the code that hypothesis generated and
then fix all these like type and the
right strategy to use so
um yeah so if you're super lazy nobody
can help you I can't help you
hypervisors can't help you so uh
sometimes you know we we like you know
we're Engineers we like being lazy but
don't be too lazy here okay so uh that's
the end of my talk and thank you so much
for listening
I'll go back to the first slide if
nothing's happened you can take a last
chance to take a picture of it okay I'll
quickly go back
oh is there any questions I don't know
uh what's going on here so
yeah we there's a couple questions I
don't know if you've addressed them yet
I don't know if you see it uh one about
the fuzz testing
um you can't see the question if you can
read it out that would be helpful
exactly yes is hypothesis space uh the
first test thing or does it pick from a
set of
so yeah it depends on strategy again
it's the strategy is the key so uh you
know for those simple one it has been
tested many many times so they're like
they're more or less like very robust uh
but if you have something very specific
you can write your own strategy so it
yeah it depends on the strategy I would
say
what about this if they correctly about
this January of uh there was a random
factor that I yeah so it uh so uh for
the strategy I think uh for example
uh for the the string right like the
text that I show you the example so it
will pick uh the the for some of them is
obviously you have to test like the
anti-string that that would be the edge
case like and also maybe it's great with
one character and then two character but
it won't test like three character four
character because you know if you know
one or two character passed and we just
assume the rest will be fine so
um yeah so that it won't be random I
think it would be some a certain
strategy that you know you know which
other Edge case and it must be test
but you can also provide the case that
it must be tested there are more like
Advanced usage of it so I'm just
covering the basic right now so yeah